bueno
ah
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta entrevista
hoy tenemos el placer de hablar con la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der leyen esta destacada política
alemana es la encargada de preparar y
aplicar la respuesta de la unión europea
a la guerra en ucrania está con nosotros
desde la comisión en bruselas
buenos días señora presidenta
tras las múltiples rondas de sanciones
hay repercusiones para los rusos y los
europeos sobre todo un aumento de los
precios de la energía y del precio de
los productos agrícolas
teniendo en cuenta que ucrania es el
granero de europa
usted está preparando un plan de
seguridad alimentaria podría darnos
algunos detalles
a min x
es muy grave que ahora ucrania no sea
capaz de sembrar el trigo que necesita
el mundo
ucrania provee el 12 por ciento del
suministro mundial de trigo en lo que
respecta a la unión europea hacemos un
gran productor y proveedor de cereales
así que lo que nos preocupa no es tanto
una cuestión de seguridad alimentaria
para la unión europea
sino una cuestión de seguridad
alimentaria a nivel mundial
también nos interesan los precios de los
alimentos
así que a partir de la semana que viene
emitiremos diferentes dictámenes sobre
cómo apoyar por ejemplo a los
agricultores y cómo aumentar la
producción de trigo que nos hace falta
ahora debido a la guerra de ucrania
veremos qué se puede hacer con las
tierras retiradas de la producción y dar
diferentes opciones a los estados
miembros sobre cómo reaccionar ante
estos líneas de las vuelo de miles de
linz que quiere que alemania acepte un
embargo sobre el gas y el petróleo rusos
como ciudadana alemana puede confirmar
que su país es quien bloquea un embargo
y está tratando de cambiar eso
y soy ante todo presidente de la
comisión europea esa es mi rol
si miramos la dependencia respecto a los
combustibles fósiles rusos somos
demasiado dependientes de estos y
tenemos que salir de esta situación y
salir de forma que no perjudiquemos
demasiado nuestra economía
porque esta es la ventaja más fuerte que
tenemos contra putin y su tierra como
acabo de explicar con las sanciones las
hay porque somos fuertes económicamente
pero podemos hacer algo para reducir
nuestra dependencia respecto a los
combustibles fósiles rusos lo primero es
que estamos buscando con nuestros amigos
los estadounidenses por ejemplo si es
posible disponer de más gas natural
licuado para sustituir para diversificar
el gas ruso
esto es muy importante y va bien
si rusia nos quitará el gas hoy
podríamos superar este invierno tenemos
mucha energía y gases
el segundo paso es invertir fuertemente
en energías renovables son locales crean
puestos de trabajo en casa son buenas
para el planeta y son buenas para
nuestra seguridad energética
estas inversiones en energías renovables
son inversiones estratégicas y el tercer
punto es muy simple pero muy importante
todos los europeos pueden contribuir
ahorrando energía cuanta menos energía
usemos más fácil será para nosotros
salir de la dependencia de los
combustibles fósiles de rúsia
you by the air estará en bruselas la
próxima semana para la cumbre de la otan
dedicada a la situación en ucrania
cuál es el objetivo de esta cumbre dado
que la otan no quiere entrar en una
guerra con rusia
wow
esto es ante todo una cuestión de la
otan
y la otan tiene muy claro que lo tan
defender a la alianza pero en territorio
de la otan es una decisión de la otan
que no puedo comentar
pero para nosotros lo importante lo que
hemos visto como ya les dije es que
nuestra respuesta a la agresión de putin
y a la cruel guerra que ha iniciado es
muy fuerte
se trata de asegurarnos básicamente de
paralizar su economía y que sea incapaz
de seguir rellenando su cofre de guerra
y esto tiene un gran impacto en la bolsa
de valores de rusia está cerrada desde
hace tres semanas
porque para rusia ya no es posible abrir
la ix y además hemos visto a todas las
empresas internacionales que están
saliendo de rusia esto tiene un enorme
efecto en la economía de rusia en este
momento pero también un enorme efecto a
largo plazo un impacto duradero
el presidente putin tiene que pagar un
precio y esta es nuestra fortaleza la
unión europea
el segundo paso es que apoyamos al
valiente pueblo ucraniano con el
suministro de armas en su lucha
esto es algo que la unión europea nunca
había hecho antes pero ahora somos
capaces de suministrar este apoyo a los
ucranianos y hacemos todo lo posible
para apoyarlos también en las
negociaciones que ya comenzaron siempre
que podamos ayudarlos lo haremos
disco-pub los sus ya no se está hablando
de apoyo esta semana de los líderes de
polonia la república checa y eslovaquia
viajaron a kiev para mostrar su
solidaridad con ucrania y con el
presidente excelencia
países que son miembros del grupo
euroescéptico vice gar
fue valiente o irresponsable por su
parte viajar
y fue para ayudar a desviar la atención
de sus propias deficiencias en lo que
respecta al estado de derecho
y
es un mensaje valiente y fue bueno que
se diera si hay algo que putin no
cálculo es la unidad de la unión europea
y la unidad de la unión con por ejemplo
nuestros amigos estadounidenses
canadienses británicos
tampoco calculó la velocidad y la
intensidad de las sanciones que hemos
impuesto
estamos unidos en este muy claro mensaje
a la agresión de putin sin duda alguna
esto no significa que este sea el único
tema
también estamos trabajando en los otros
temas que tenemos con nuestros estados
miembros
pero por el momento es realmente
importante dar una respuesta muy muy
firme
no puede ser que un autócrata ataque un
país soberano que tiene derecho a la
integridad de su territorio
y
no puede ser que ese tema la influencia
que rusia intenta ejercer sobre otros
países vecinos
es una democracia que se enfrenta a una
autocracia y por lo tanto aquí somos uno
el ejército ruso bombardea sin piedad
objetivos civiles como el teatro de
mariupol
el kremlin se niega a poner fin a los
combates a pesar de los llamados de la
corte penal internacional
de vladimir putin ser juzgado por la
corte penal internacional nacional
y
creo que es absolutamente correcto y
necesario que se investiguen los
crímenes de guerra y los responsables de
esto es nunca verdad
es atroz lo que vemos es cruel es
inhumano y es bueno que estas
investigaciones avancen y que los
responsables tengan que dar la cara por
lo que han hecho también creo que es una
cuestión de orden internacional que
tenemos que mantener
y si miramos por ejemplo lo que sucedió
en la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas
hubo una victoria contundente para
mantener el orden internacional
141 países condenaron a rusia
mientras que sólo cuatro países lo
apoyaron entre a siria bielorrusia y
corea del norte estos fueron los únicos
países que apoyaron a rusia
todos los demás se abstuvieron o
condenaron a rusia por sus acciones
de allegiant y ursula von der leyen
usted fue la persona que le abrió la
puerta de la unión europea a ucrania
pero en la cumbre de ver sal los líderes
de la unión europea descartaron una
adhesión rápida es eso un error y está
descartado un proceso de adhesión rápida
para ucrania e incluso para moldavia y
georgia porque se correría el riesgo de
enfadar a vladimir putin
por el contrario creo que hubo un fuerte
mensaje por parte de versace
en primer lugar muy claro los 27 países
dijeron unánimemente que ucrania hace
parte de nuestra familia europea
y que estamos forjando un camino hacia
la ampliación
de hecho el que el presidente excelencia
haya presentado sus solicitudes aplica y
puso en marcha el proceso y el consejo
le pidió ahora a la comisión europea que
emitieron dictamen esto está en proceso
tu
opinión
normalmente esto toma años antes de
ocurrir y con ucrania nos ha llevado
semanas hoy tuve una reunión con el
presidente selenski y hablamos sobre el
camino a seguir
para elaborar el dictamen de la comisión
europea normalmente a un país se le
hacen de cuatro a cinco mil preguntas
diferentes
es un cuadernillo muy grande y se
necesitan años para responder a estas
preguntas y dar la información infomex
aquí nos encontramos en una situación
extraordinaria
necesitamos soluciones a medida y
tenemos que ser creativos
ya tenemos mucha información sobre
ucrania
tenemos el profundo y amplio acuerdo de
libre comercio
que ya cubre el 70% de los temas
así que la comisión puede sacar mucha
información de aquí
acabo de decir que conectamos la red
eléctrica por ejemplo
tenemos roaming con ucrania
ya se ha hecho mucho en los últimos años
para acercarnos a wuhan
cuál es la esencia de lo que estoy
describiendo
el objetivo a ser más rápidos y emitir
en unos meses este dictamen
ese es el siguiente paso que tiene que
dar la comisión y hacer todo lo posible
para apoyar a ucrania del rendimiento de
un proceso que se ha iniciado
gracias señora presidenta de la comisión
europea ursula von der leyen por ser
nuestra invitada hasta pronto
[Música]